bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct à vis de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la majorité se lance
dans les législatives photo de famille
affiche de campagne aux docks
d'aubervilliers aujourd'hui pour un
séminaire de formation qui réunissait
les quelques 500 candidats déjà investi
emmanuel macron en personne est venu les
galvaniser est ce que c'est à lui de le
faire on se posera la question passera
également au crible les différents
profils parité diversité mais surtout
stratégie de la majorité dans cette
campagne grande décryptage d'un instant
avec nos invités sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin ce soir va nous aider à
mieux cerner le nouvel ordre mondial
dans lequel la guerre en ukraine nous
fait entrer chine russie etats unis
europe il a été ambassadeur de france à
pékin puis à moscou nous lui demanderons
aussi l'union européenne peut et doit
incarner une troisième voie face à ce
qui ressemble de plus en plus à une
nouvelle guerre froide le diplomate jean
maurice ripert est avec nous ce soir en
fin de partie pris ce soir 2 a franchi
jean rémi baudot pour la politique macro
nappe toujours pas de premier ministre
est alors et puis l'économie avec fanny
guinochet alerte au rouge écarlate sur
notre déficit commercial voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au rendez
vous c'est devenu son obsession depuis
sa réélection emmanuel macron s'implique
personnellement dans les législatives
comment s'assurer une majorité stable à
l'assemblée face à la possible arrivée
en force des extrêmes au palais bourbon
on en parle avec vous ce soir bruno
cautrès bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous politologue au cevipof de sciences
po à paris bon soir benjamin morel
bienvenus maître de conférences en droit
public à l'université paris ii panthéon
assas bonsoir stéphane soupe steg on
sera ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau directeur du département opinion
à l'ifop sauce on a besoin de savoir
comment travaillent les sondeurs sur ces
législatives c'est compliqué piel
d'amont d'un gamin qui a suivi toute
cette journée de formation aux docks
d'aubervilliers de la majorité elle a vu
la plupart de ces nouveaux candidats
investis va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant mais juste après le billet
de stéphane blakowski bonsoir stéphane
si j'ai bien compris le décor est
quasiment planter quelques petits
rouages encore à affiner les grands
blocs sont dans la campagne
[Musique]
les fans si j'ai bien compris ce soir je
vais y compris la bataille des juristes
législatives est sur le point de
commencer mais pas encore tout à fait
prêt on passe les troupes en revue et on
passe aussi le matériel en revue au cas
il y aurait quelques boulons à resserrer
donc même pour nous les journalistes et
les choses qui changent les nouvelles
appellations donc dans deux trois jours
pourra être réglé plus question par
exemple de rançon de confondre ensemble
là qu il ait de la coalition et
renouveau le parti ça c'est nous
renaissance renaissance le parti voilà
ça dans deux ou trois jours c'est plus
possible et pareil pour la nouvelle
union populaire il va falloir s'habituer
à dire nulle parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on dit on dit nul vous dites alors
moi je disais du ps le week-end d'achats
avant le week-end et puis j'ai entendu
mélenchon ce week-end et je voulais que
il ne dit pas du ps irin hub
pour le couteur ça va on s'est bien fait
alarm
alors on l'a nul pourquoi pas
attention tout est politique pour
marquer qu'elle ait eu de l'écologie l
es deux socialistes deux asocial par
n'en devient muet dans la bouche de jean
loup dans la journée que mélenchon donc
ses alliés comptent un peu pour du
beurre mais ça on vous essayé de semer
un peu la zizanie à gauche c'est ça oui
ça serait amusant d'ailleurs si fabien
roussel et et jean luc mélenchon ne
s'entendait pas s'il roussel dizaine ups
coûte que coûte et que mélenchon lui
disait mais non c'est nul ça
illustrerait un petit peu le fait qu'
ils ont parfois du mal à s'entendre
entendu ce matin que tartas pardon
boivent avait retiré sa candidature qui
faisait polémique c'est fabien roussel
qui avait demandé sa tête donc on
pensait que cette victoire communiste en
fait manuellement par why un trip pour
dire mais si vous croyez que les
communistes on avoir un esprit tueur
certainement pas donc c'est quand même
un petit peu tendu et puis le truc c'est
que en fait quand ça frotte vous est ce
qui se passe ça finit par part chercher
et quand ça chauffe ça peu cramé à
attention pas d'huile sur le feu
uniquement de l'huile dans les rouages
on écoute alexis corbière une douceur
angélique ce matin
utilisons ces cinq semaines pour
commander rage valoriser la belle
nouvelle populaire que nous avons mis en
place je ne nie pas je ne conteste pas
qu évidemment nous sommes des femmes des
hommes de caractère et fabien roussel
est un dirigeant est une combattante
politique mais j'invite chacun à ce que
on exacerbe pas éventuellement ce qui
ici ou là est un frottement
parce que je n'en vois pas l'intérêt on
a la hantise du frottement à
l'affrontement qui chauffe et c est donc
ça même pour les socialistes ça peut
joint un peu rauque est ce que on se
rend compte qu'en fait à paris on a
signé un accord où les socialistes
étaient d'accord mais en région enfin
dans les départements tu as forcément et
pas mal de fédération qui préfèrent
soutenir un dissident plutôt que
soutenir le candidat de la nuque il y
aura peut-être même plus de socialistes
d'ici donc deux socialistes nous mars
avec nos invités un instant pour
terminer dans le dans le camp d'emmanuel
macron ça frotte au cenou pas ça chauffe
regarder la tête qui faisait mercredi
soir là mon sens que ça frottait en
coulisses je vous dirai ça peut être un
show fait comment on va bientôt ils en
sortent un petit peu contrarié puis
aussi le fait que il ya moins de
ralliement de députés l'air qu'on avait
envisagé sarkozy avait déjeuné avec
bruno le maire en disant moi je vous
ramène 60 galère on va faire un vrai
force d'appoint bon finalement christian
jacob a fait ses comptes dès que ça à la
fin de la foire qu'on compte les bouses
et ben écoutez on nous avait annoncé il
ya trois semaines un mois une
cinquantaine après on est passé une
trentaine après une dizaine maintenant
on nous dit entre 5 et 7 et là où il y
en a 1 effectivement peut-être y en aura
deux 2 tu me rends trois pékins
arrondissement said he amendes prévues
en fait est et reste le cas marine le
pen alors jusque là très discrète dans
cette campagne quand marine le pen est
en vacances le rn va life qui dément est
un peu en vacances le gym est là et les
revenus et l'attaqué mélenchon aller ce
soir sur tf1 mais ça frotte comme
partout à regarder notamment région paca
savait qu'à eux et reines du nord et les
rênes du sud sont pas toujours d'accord
donc philippe vardon le d'eux m'a dit ça
serait peut-être bien conseillé à
l'hexagone pour avoir des sièges en paca
et le 3 mai on annonce que effectivement
il est viré en tout cas on lui retire
son indice clic son investiture
d'envoyer ça frotte ça chauffe le voir
et finalement même aux arènes donc il va
falloir serrer qu'elle connaissait la
neige de montech il faut frotter sa
cervelle celui de l'adversaire il faut
trop froid
merci beaucoup merci pour ce pour ce
regard stéphane alors qui peut espérer
quoi à ce stade elle est compliquée
cette législative parce que les trois
blocs la recomposition
du paysage politique change un peu
changer un peu la donne le fait que ce
soir pour partir de l'actualité emmanuel
macron s'implique personnellement
apparemment d'après ce qui nous parvient
il tape assez dur sur jean luc mélenchon
le troisième tour n'existe pas ne vous y
fiez pas il tape aussi sur marine le pen
la renvoyant à la candidate de
l'exclusion est ce que s'assigne une
forme de fébrilité ou c'est la logique
assez pense que c'est d'abord la logique
institutionnelle c'est aussi la logique
du tempérament d'emmanuel macron de
conduire la bataille du même mais c'est
vrai qu'il s'est mis dans une situation
un peu délicate il a laissé un peu le
champ libre à jean luc mélenchon et ça a
permis à jean luc mélenchon de réaliser
quelque chose qui au plan de la
dynamique électorale est toujours très
important celui qui arrive à imposer les
conditions de la bataille le thème de la
bataille le terrain de la bataille en
matière électorale il a souvent un petit
avantage ces primes législatives avec ce
modèle mais % des inscrits sans risque
pour les banques une dimension quand
même nationale elle est consécutive à
l'élection présentielle elle n'est pas
un reflet l'élection présidentielle par
contre elle est consécutive quand même à
l'élection présidentielle et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là emmanuel
lacroix pour le moment je n'ai pas assez
fait voler la vedette parce que quand il
va nommer son premier ministre il va
sans doute reprendre la lumière mais là
il s'agit il s'est fait un peu voler la
vedette stéphane zumsteeg expliquez nous
comment vous travaillez on a on a du mal
à vraiment comprendre comment pour 577
élections dans chaque circonscription
on peut mesurer les intentions de vote
c'est bien la difficulté d'en mesurer
des intentions de vote c'est possible ce
qui est vraiment compliqué c'est de le
traduire en projection au piège
évidemment bon alors je ne suis pas là
pour critiquer ce que font certains de
mes copains parce que vous avez pu voir
dans les médias jusqu'à présent était
calculée sur la base du résultat de
l'élection présidentielle ce qui n'a pas
véritablement de sens parce que je vous
donne quelques chiffres il ya cinq ans
marine le pen obtient 21 % des voix au
premier tour le lycée candidats
n'obtiendront 13% quelques semaines
après pour huit sièges jean luc
mélenchon que les 19% ces candidats
n'obtenait plus que 11 % va d'ailleurs
revoir la carte en dessous de ce que
vous me parlez des résultats du premier
tour c'est une carte cas découpage vous
la voyez est là s'afficher avec toutes
les circonscriptions il ya du jaune
c'est macron il ya du bleu c'est marine
le pen il ya du rouge c'est jean luc
mélenchon premier tour de la présidence
elle compte tenu des dynamiques dont par
les bonobos 13 qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
éventuellement sur quelques tendances
qu'on pourrait retrouver au soir du
premier tour des législatives la
dynamique et côté mélenchon la
communication la dynamique médiatique et
politique donc elle est du côté de jean
luc mélenchon qui a réussi non parole
d'apple a quand même réussi à imprimer
son tempo et ça c'est un coup politique
très fort de là à dire que jean luc
mélenchon est aujourd'hui la campagne ne
fait que commencer évidemment il va se
passer plein de choses de là à dire que
jean luc mélenchon et que la nuque est
aujourd'hui parti pour gagner la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
est en est un est un scénario qui n'est
pas impossible mais qui est quand même
pas la seule la situation la plus le
pronostic le plus probable on s'oriente
quand même malgré tout fin vers une
peut-être pas l'identification mais vers
une confirmation de ce qu'on a vu à
l'élection présidentielle des français
et on voit bien on n'a pas encore le nom
du premier ministre on a déjà le nom du
directeur de campagne de renaissance et
emmanuel macron sur quoi est ce qu'il va
capitaliser et expliquer écouter vous
m'avez élu président de la république
souci de cohérence français ne sont pas
opposée à la cohabitation vous dire vous
avez eu l'impression de la république ce
n'est pas pour avoir une une assemblée
nationale d'une couleur différente cette
semaine plus tard mais j'aimerais ça
c'est vrai que c'est une constante de la
vème république la dynamique de
l'élection présidentielle confortait aux
législatives avec une majorité qui lui
est donnée contenu voilà de la
recomposition est ce que on en est
exactement dans ce schéma là où c'est un
peu plus compliqué alors c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué c'est à dire que on
dit beaucoup les français veulent donner
une majorité au président de la
république en fait c'est pas tout à fait
vrai quand on regarde ce qui se passe
aux législatives vous avez un électorat
de la majorité qui est très content il a
gagné et donc ils se mobilisent c'est
normal et vous avez un électorat de
l'opposition qui groggy il a perdu et
comme il a perdu ben une maj une grande
partie en fait s'abstient ne va pas
voter et donc vous avez cet effet des
mobilisations là vous avez plusieurs
caractéristiques qui laisse à penser que
ce sera peut-être pas tout à fait le cas
la mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon réussit à faire
passer d'une défaite une victoire et
donc pour le coup il est en capacité de
mobiliser cette base électorale de
l'autre côté emmanuel macron pour
l'instant à une base électorale qui est
mobilisée par nature en réalité parce
que c'est une base électorale assez peu
abstentionnistes du côté du r n vous
avez pas de mobilisation parce que pour
l'instant vous n'êtes pas de campagne
une autre règle fondamentale de ces
élections législatives c'est que si vous
voulez avoir une chance de l'emporter il
faut unir votre camp politique tout
bêtement parce que à moins d'avoir des
triangulaires si vous n'y fiez pas votre
camp politique vous avez très peu de
chance d'envoyer des allégations de la
force en effet de la nuque c'est d'avoir
unifier un camp politique pour envoyer
le maximum de candidats ensuite le point
qui fait que je rejoins tout à fait ce
qui a été dit du point de vue des
difficultés corps et la gauche à obtenir
une majorité c'est que dans une période
de tripartition de la vie politique en
réalité vous avez un vrai avantage
comparatif des centres si jamais le
candidat la reine se retrouve face à un
candidat et rennes la gauche bonon mal
on va jouer le castor et voter pour lui
si jamais le candidat de la reine se
retrouve face à un candidat de la nuque
il ya des chances qu'une grande partie
l'électorat de droite s'abstiennent voir
vote pour lr eux mêmes donc si vous
voulez cette position centrale
aujourd'hui dans le champ politique fait
qu'il y ait un avantage comparatif dont
on voit mal à ce stade là qu'est ce qui
pourrait le contrevent suarez abondent à
gaza on sera ravi de vous avoir sur ce
plateau vous revenez d'aubervillers on
va vous interroger sur les images que
vous avez vu aujourd'hui que comprendre
de cette nouvelle au moule ou à son 2022
de deux candidats mais donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya forcément que des duels dans
cette élection législative au second
tour il y avait un seul duel en 2017 une
seule triangulaire une seule
triangulaire pardonnez moi et donc c'est
ce que vous nous expliquer c'est parce
que le mode de scrutin favorise plutôt
les duels qu'on risque d'avoir à nouveau
au fond une prime aux candidats centrale
oui effectivement en plus on voit que
c'est une élection il peut y avoir plus
d'abstention on parle en suffrages
exprimés donc effectivement s'il ya cinq
ans il ya eu une seule triangulaire là
en plus avec une union de la gauche on
peut imaginer qu'ils en aient très peu
aussi cette fois ci et pour rebondir à
ce que vous disiez il ya quand même
effectivement des inquiétudes je pense
qu'il y avait vraiment une volonté de la
majorité de se dire nous aussi il faut
qu'on rentre en clair d'autant voilà il
faut qu'on gagne un peu vite puisque là
on a laissé mélenchon jean luc mélenchon
occuper le terrain là il faut y aller
manuel macron à 10 à partir de cette
seconde là il vous reste 33 jours il
faut y aller dès maintenant on peut
rester encore un peu sur les blocs avant
de venir à la majorité c'est pas du tout
les même territoire que se partagent au
fond les grands blocs
jean luc mélenchon
lectorat plutôt urbain marine le pen la
france périphérique le nord l'est est ce
que ça veut dire au fond ils n'ont même
pas besoin de de rentrer en conflit de
campagne est certain c'est que la
géographique est issu de l'élection
présidentielle à fait effectivement à
montrer des clivages territoriaux assez
vertigineux la progression du
rassemblement national dans les zones
rurales est très impressionnante s'est
pas seulement que marine le pen a
progressé en voix sait aussi que ces
voix sont beaucoup plus étalés sur
l'ensemble du territoire elle retrouve
ses bastions du nord-est où on a
l'impression que c'est maintenant devenu
une véritable place forte du sud-est et
en plus le phénomène s'est étendu et ça
c'est une progression qui est continu en
2017 on l'avait déjà vu ça s'accentue en
2022 donc marine le pen va sans doute
miser sur la campagne de proximité
j'imagine comme les républicains c'est
d'essayer de jouer au maximum
de l'ancrage local pour les républicains
ça va être absolument fondamental de
jouer cette carte-là pour marine le pen
et le rassemblement national pour le
moment on peut s'interroger
effectivement l'absence de messages
l'absence de stratégie aller sur tf1
elle aussi s'est fait voler la vedette
par mélenchon elle est elle aussi elle
est partie en vacances il s'agit
maintenant de reprendre pied dans la
dans la campagne dans gros enjeu pour
elle c'est à dire de capitaliser sur sa
seconde place et le nombre de voix très
important qu'elle a réalisé et fameuse
robe steak jeu va vous demander de me
donner des fourchettes mais quand même
un peu juste pour comprendre déjà on
peut se dire que ces trois grands blocs
aurons un groupe sans trop prendre de
risques quinze députés ça c'est sûr à
gauche n'est blessé c'est une évidence
aurait la majorité présidentielle
évidemment puisque l'on joue là c'est
d'avoir la majorité absolue voir une
majorité très large au rassemblement
national c'est pas forcément fait un
groupe de quinze députés mais je sais
tout à fait envisageable évidemment mais
là encore le fera semblant nationale est
victime de ce scrutin les élections
législatives c'est le pire scrutin pour
un parti comme le rassemblement national
je reprends des chiffres intentions lui
député forte abstention je ne suis pas
persuadé que le rassemblement national
réussira à garder
la mobilisation de l'électorat de marine
le pen j'en suis vraiment pas persuadé
frappant il suffit d'écouter jordan
garder la caisse qui dit quand ils
passent dans les médias c'est nous
voulons avoir le maximum de députés
possible très bien mais ce qu'il faut
déjà ce serait une belle victoire
d'avoir un groupe donc moi je suis un
opposant à emmanuel macron dans
l'hémicycle de risque ne pas être
une tendance voire une certaine la
gauche aura très probablement plus
d'élus que le réseau national ce qui
changera tout d'un visionnaire
ça va changer évidemment toute la
physionomie du quinquennat ben alors on
va attendre encore un petit peu pour le
savoir on va s'intéresser aux candidats
ensemble le point d'exclamation si j'ai
bien compris c'est le nouveau nom elle
va vous avez passé la journée au
séminaire de formation des des candidats
investis par la majorité présidentielle
à aubervilliers exactement on était avec
clément méric et pierre yves deheunynck
on s'est donc rendu dans cette ville de
la proche banlieue parisienne au
séminaire de la majorité alors les
candidats et leur directeur de campagne
étaient invités au menu est bien une
journée de rencontres de formation
d'atelier mais là où il y avait le plus
de monde c'est là c'était au stand photo
un studio photo plusieurs petites
cabines les candidats se font tirer le
portrait et puis après ça ils pourront
décider d'incruster le visage des
manuels macron sur leurs affiches de
campagne c'est un petit peu pour
l'anecdote sinon il ya vraiment eu des
ateliers sur la communication sib est un
terrien scène porte parole du
gouvernement à délivrer ses conseils
un autre a été plus centrée cette fois
sur le programme il était dirigé par
gabriel attal qui est l'actuel
porte-parole on lui a demandé ce qu'il
conseillait aux candidats pour lui il ne
faut pas être dans l'attaqué mais bel et
bien dans la riposte et oui il faut
aussi être capable de riposter de
répondre aux attaques une campagne c'est
du débarrasser parfois des attaques et
donc il faut être capable d'être
outillés pour vous répondre ça c'est
tout le tout la responsabilité de
l'équipe de campagne que de fournir 100
alors vous avez regardé la liste de très
près à et vous en retenez cette femme et
cette grande famille de candidats
ensemble exactement la majorité les plus
nombreux ce sont les députés sortants et
puis il ya ensuite et bien la famille
des ministres certains ont décidé de se
lancer dans la bataille des législatives
pour la première fois c'est le cas
d'elisabeth bornes ou de jean michel
blanquer on le voit il passe pas les
contrôler un quand ils vont aussi r il
ya une autre catégorie celle des élus
locaux très importante dans ces
investitures des conseillers
départementaux ou encore des mères on
peut penser à karl olive notamment le
maire de poissy et puis myriam c'est la
modernité actuellement la majorité des
familles sont recomposées on accueille
des transfuges de la droite et de la
gauche alors on va être honnête on alain
quand même vu plus de droite que de
gauche eric woerth par exemple étaient
présents aujourd'hui constance le grip
toute nouvelle rallier ou encore
alexandra monnaie elle était jusqu'il ya
peu chez les jeunes républicains ensuite
et c'est aussi assez notable dans cette
liste quand on a épluché on a vu
beaucoup de collaborateurs
parlementaires ou de conseillers
politiques
c'est le cas par exemple de paul midy
c'est le directeur général du parti en
marche ou encore de david amiel qui
était conseiller à l'elysée pendant les
deux premières années du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron alors du coup on parle
un peu moins de la société civile même
si elles existent benjamin haddad son
visage vous dit peut-être quelque chose
il est chercheur en relations
internationales puis encore vincent
guillermin qui lui est éleveur de
volailles et puis comme dans toutes les
familles bail à ce qu'on invite plus aux
soirées des députés qu'aurait bien les
allées dans exactement être investis
mais on leur a préféré d'autres
candidats alors ils sont bien décidés
pour certains s'incrustait malgré tout
puisqu'ils peuvent partir en d'ici là on
va en parler est ce qu'ils sont
représentatifs de la société française
tous ces candidats vous avez regardé la
diversité j'imagine la parité alors il
ya une petite anecdote dans les
premières libres d'investiture on avait
les métiers des candidats puis après ils
ont disparu alors on jure que c'est du
hasard mais on s'aperçoit que non il ya
quand même beaucoup soin de gens qui
font de la politique soit de gens qui
sont assez sp plus comme on les appelle
alors justement est ce qu'il ya un
manque de diversité sociale on a posé la
question à stanislas guerrini délégué
général dans marche que vous n'êtes pas
parti de cesse mais plus de classes
supérieures je crois pas vraiment très
sincèrement je vois beaucoup de profils
d'âgés kunter des rues triste
d'infirmiers et d'infirmières voyager ni
le profil de la majorité présentielle en
vous citant ces professions là et je
crois encore une fois que la diversité
des profils présentés là est présenté en
2017 est infiniment plus grande
que celle que les partis politiques
traditionnels présentés aux dernières
élections merci infiniment pour ce tour
d'horizon complet en images vous voyez
au ses sourcils bruno cautrès une
diversité infiniment plus grandes
escales et elle est vraiment
représentative cette majorité non pas
vraiment non pas vraiment en 2017 on
avait vu un double renouvellement
générationnel d'abord et paritaire on
avait vu aussi un peu de renouvellement
sociologique puisqu'il y avait un peu
plus de personnalité issue du monde de
l'entreprise
de personnalités issues de chef
d'entreprise mais globalement c'était
toujours une sociologie de csp + voire
plus plusieurs on parle d'une fracture
au pluriel des fractures la france qui
fument des clopes et qui roulent au
diesel oui pour reprendre la formule de
benjamin griveaux de mon prénom dans des
assemblées effective effectivement dans
la précédente législature tout cas celle
qui termine son mandat je crois qu'on ne
comptait qu'un agriculteur et un ouvrier
un baptiste moreau a bien que voilà donc
sans doute que le responsable la
république en marche à à raison souligné
qu' et c'est bien qu'il y ait des
agriculteurs et qu'il aidait des
personnes issues du monde de
l'entreprise mais on voit que ça ça
fonctionne quand même un petit peu
aguicher sociologique fermé
oui on a même dernière assemblée qui en
fait était beaucoup plus homogène
socialement initialement que les
précédentes parce qu'en réalité il faut
pas oublier que le rôle des partis
politiques c'est pas seulement de
d'incarner une restructuration
idéologique de l'espace politique le
rôle d'un parti politique c'est
également de former des élites c'est
d'aller chercher des gens à la sortie
des deux du lycée et de les former
ensuite dans les institutions du parti
des gens qui parfois viennent d'un
milieu populaire où viennent d'un milieu
agricole où viennent acceptera etc et
tout d'un coup et bien à travers ce
cursus honorum au sein du parti ils
peuvent un jour à
calais vous
et quand vous adresser directement la
société civile souvent c'est une société
civile qui évidemment a le temps de
s'occuper de politique s'intéresse à la
politique or on sait que vous avez pour
le coup une un biais sociologique est
très très important et enfin une société
civile qui vous ressemble or pour le
coup l'espace politique de la république
en marche son électorat est plutôt un
électorat csp + en ce sens il est
représentatif des sens et des
responsables hector aventures de son
électorat ce n'est pas un angle mort
important est ce que les électeurs
regardent ça ou au contraire au fond
c'est narcissique il faut se retrouver
retrouver son image sociologique pour
voter pour un candidat les électeurs ne
le regarde son de pâques candidat par
candidat nous regarde pas quelle est la
profession des différents candidats dans
leur circonscription
après que effectivement ce la classe
politique de manière générale et les
prochains députés soit et d'un niveau
socio culturel plus élevé que la moyenne
pratiquée tous la même stratégie côté
insoumis qui reste une femme de ménage
qui a mené un combat ici à l'assemblée
une fois de plus on aura des députés qui
sont peut-être qu'ils ceux qui vivent
mieux leur vie que des français en
général mais tout ça n'est pas né n'est
pas n'est pas nouveau en fin autrefois
il retrouve il ya quelques desserts il
ya quelques années encore on dit que la
droite il ya une surreprésentation des
professions libérales mais qu'au parti
socialiste
dominion à gauche eh bien il fallait de
fonctionnaire territorial ou et nous
venir des mutuelles pour être élu bon il
y avait cette distorsion elle existait
déjà c'est effectivement déplacés on
parle plus de start up nation n'en
parlait pas il ya 30 ans évidemment et
peut-être que dans le cas bien précis de
cette dernière législature c'est
différent sociologique par rapport à
l'intégralité de la france ont été un
peu plus marqué en tout cas ont retenu
un peu plus l'attention des français
mais de là à dire je retour un tel parce
qu'il a le même métier que moi où je ne
vote pas pour lui parce qu'il est à
l'opposé des grilles sociale je ne pense
pas que ça se joue un rôle essentiel
pour un votant et à d'autres profitent
d'ailleurs que ça contribue à une fois
de plus creusé élargir le fossé qui
existe entre des citoyens et leur classe
pas du temps et des profils qu'on
pourrait vous donner y en a beaucoup à
un les noms sont évidemment en ligne il
ya par exemple tient le témoin de
mariage d'emmanuel macro qui a été
conseiller social de muriel pénicaud
marque créera çi qui lui va être investi
dans une circonscription des français de
l'étranger en suisse ou encore astrid
panossian on parlait d' exemplarité
sociologique une des rares femmes cac 40
qui a été un mandat social chez chez
unibail elle a fait partie des tous
premiers marcheurs elle était même à la
la fondation pour signer les statuts
dans marche elsa ya quand même 60 sa
circonscription gelés pourquoi est ce
qu'on craint des dissidences qu'est-ce
qui est en tractation alors
effectivement on va évidemment on
détaille on regarde toutes les
investitures mais on regarde surtout à
chaque liste de circonscription celle
qui manque alors il y en a une
cinquantaine qui manque pour l'instant
il n'est pas sûr qu'il ya des candidats
absolument partout il ya des situations
locales à gérer et puis il ya des
situations est ce qu'on va oui ou non
mettre un candidat
ensemble soit dans un territoire où il
ya un fort risque pour le rassemblement
national c'est le cas dans l'aisne par
exemple soit parce que c'est un député
socialiste sortant qui a clairement
qu'il n'a pas eu l'investiture de la
nuque et finalement on va peut-être pas
lui mettre deux candidats en face il ya
certaines voix la situation comme ça
pareil à droite où il fait poutre
travaille encore des deux côtés mais on
va effectivement scruter là où il n'y a
pas de candidat ce sera forcément un
signe politique alors vous avez commencé
à en parler on va terminer avec ces
candidats investis sous la bannière
ensemble qui faisait partie des
républicains on les appelle les
transfuges constance le grip par exemple
robin reda marine brenier trois députés
sortants aient l'air qui ont donc
franchi le rubicon en rejoignant la
majorité présidentielle on a voulu
savoir comment réagissent et au fond les
électeurs sur le terrain stéphanie des
pierres s'est rendu dans la sixième
circonscription des hauts-de-seine de
constance le grip reportage
tous les députés de la majorité à
aubervilliers ce matin et au milieu il y
à une sortante venue des républicains
constance le grip a saisi la main tendue
par emmanuel macron elle découvre sa
nouvelle famille politique
rejoint une autre famille politique dont
en réalité
les idées et propositions seront très
proches de celles qui me sont chers je
pense qu'elles vont pouvoir plus
aisément plus confortablement et plus
efficacement surtout plus efficacement
et utilement pour le pays est reportée à
l'intérieur de la majorité présentielle
au menu de sa journée un atelier
programme histoire d'être bien au point
sur les positions défendues par son
nouveau parti est de convaincre ses
électeurs je suis consciente du fait que
sur le terrain dans ma circonscription
il ya un travail
d'explications à fournir dans sa
circonscription au coeur des
hauts-de-seine emmanuel macron a
recueilli 43% des suffrages au premier
tour de la présidentielle un score qui a
pesé dans la décision de constance le
grip à neuilly les électeurs ne savent
pas tout ce qu'elle a changé d'étiquette
politique depuis dimanche mais parmi
ceux qui savent les positions sont
tranchées
c'est très bien elle a bien fait je suis
assez pour macro donc je suis tout à
fait content qu'elle rallie qu'elle
rallie la majorité moi ça va pas une
idée complètement pas déraisonnable
compte tenu de l'état des républicains
constance le grip est passé chez makro
j'avais pas ça par contre non mais
attendez à l'est pas et l'air je regarde
ça j'avais pas vu ça qu'est ce que ça
change ben ça change que j'ai passé la
majorité présidentielle je parle de
cette majorité jeu vrai que ça a une
contrainte contre-pouvoir mais je veux
surtout pas de la gauche qui tu es
maintenant le parti ait l'air pour se
présenter dans le cadre de la majorité
présidentielle je trouve que c'est un
revirement qui n'est pas à son honneur
pour l'état-major des républicains pas
question de laisser le champ libre à
constance le grip il cherche donc en
urgence un candidat de rechange pour
l'instant on ne connaît pas celui de la
gauche à la présidentielle jean-luc
mélenchon a fait 17 % des voix dans
cette circonscription du côté de
reconquête c'est franck keller
conseiller municipal à neuilly qui est
investi le rassemblement national lui a
choisi la famille c'est marie caroline
la soeur de marine le pen qui est
candidate comme elle n'a pas encore
lancé sa campagne elle n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer
benjamin morel la stratégie dlr coûte
que coûte ancrage local restons heller
finalement que trois prises c'est peu en
pour l'instant un côté majorité
présidentielle ça veut dire quoi c on
tente le tout pour le tout ça peut
marcher un groupe sauvé oui probablement
parce que malgré tout vous avez un
ancrage local qui peut jouer notamment
dans des territoires où vous allez avoir
justement l'étiquette qui malgré tout va
compter où vous avez par ailleurs un
taux de personnes âgées qui est
important et où donc vous avez des
habitudes de vote qui ont été prises il
faut se souvenir que les régionales et
départementales et municipales ont été
plutôt un triomphe pour la droite et que
l'électeur de droite lorsqu'il a le
sentiment que l'élection est très local
et bien retourne au bercail le cas le
grip est soit un peu d'élise et on sent
que certains l'avaient été dans l'autre
sens
mais les vrais fief de droite sont
plutôt justement dans ce rural ce
périurbain et c'est là où vous pouvez en
effet avoir de manière assez facile non
pas une majorité 1 mais vous pouvez
avoir un nombre de députés satisfaisons
et où il n'est pas absurde de penser que
l air et bien perdre des plumes mais
n'en perd pas tant que ça en vaut
ensuite sur la position des verts qui
voulaient rallier emmanuel macron vous
avez en effet beaucoup qui se sont
ravisés nous end avait également
beaucoup qui pas trouvé de piste
d'atterrissage dans la majorité donc
beaucoup plus que par exemple exactement
c'est à dire qu'on voit du côté de la
république en marché de l'ensemble
maintenant que la volonté de s'étendre
vers la droite et bien implique un vrai
serment de fidélité dont ne sont pas
tout à fait tenu les élèves peut-être
c'est la question de la loyauté qui est
posée bruno cautrès quelle est la
meilleure stratégie ou fonds pour un
pour un élu de droite qui veut se
représenter basculer chez fait maquereau
ou rester chez elles r je pense que le
basculement implique comme beaucoup de
chose effectivement ça havrais ticket
sans son retour les républicains
continuent d'être dans une situation
difficile ça s'effiloche s'effiloche on
a du mal à voir où est la stratégie
aujourd'hui certains disent il faut
affirmer notre identité de 2,2 de droite
mais que veut dire affirmer une identité
droite beaucoup d'électeurs 10 mai sur
l'économique on est très proches macron
fait le boulot nous on a étudié au
cevipof le positionnement des différents
40 candidats en regardant les programmes
et en regardant vraiment de près sur les
principales dimensions de l'action
publique et c'est vrai que sur
l'économie on voit que le programme de
valérie pécresse est solide emmanuel
macron sans être parfaitement
interchangeables évidemment ils ont
quand même une vraie zone de proximité
et donc la question stratégique pour les
élèves en fonction des résultats des
législatives et je pense que de ce point
de vue là c'est le juge de paix les
élections législatives sera est ce qu'au
fond emmanuel macron a besoin d'eux
comme alliés de la majorité en termes
extrêmement concret de majorité
législative ou est-ce qu'il peut s'en
passer
s'il a impérativement besoin d'eux en
termes de majorité claire elle a
cependant la gérer que les républicains
ont sauvé l'essentiel et leurs crises
identiques effrontée les arbitres ou
sont-ils inutile qu'est ce qu'on voit
dans vos enquêtes pour terminer ce débat
s'était faite au steak sur la droite sur
la droite s'absorber déjà dans les
attendait le processus l'opération de
mise à mort définitive des républicains
n'est pas encore arrivée à son terme et
c'est capital pour la majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui de continuer
à envoyer des coups de boutoir parce que
sans donner de s'en faire de pronostic
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans ce
premier dans ces élections légistatives
il ya toute une série de
circonscriptions urbaines dont on a
parlé ou jean luc mélenchon tenue des
scores fleuves et ces circonscriptions
souvent détenues par la république en
marche basculeront très probablement à
gauche pour le compenser pour compenser
ces pertes il est capital pour macron et
les différents satellites qui composent
sa majorité d'obtenir des gains ailleurs
et où sont des marges de progression
essentiellement c'est la même chose
depuis cinq ans eh bien à droite et il
ya 120 130 sièges aujourd'hui détenue
par la droite entre les républicains lui
des élus divers droite
je suis très inquiet pour un nombre
important de ses députés bon bah c'était
très clair c'était passionnant on y voit
beaucoup plus clair merci beaucoup à
vous êtes voilà les bienvenus quand vous
voulez que pourra continuer à décrypter
les enjeux de ces législatives merci
infiniment elsa monde un gamin on va
s'arrêter à présent sur la guerre en
ukraine où les combats s'intensifient
dont l'est et le sud du pays les états
unis avec des dizaines de milliards de
dollars de dettes financières et
militaires à kiev s'affirment comme les
principaux alliés occidentaux des
ukrainiens l'europe aussi les soutiens
bien sûr mais avec l'idée de préparer
quand même l'après guerre dans quel
nouvel ordre mondial ce conflit nous
fait ils ont trait
quel rôle va jouer le géant chinois dans
cette nouvelle forme de guerre froide on
a plein de questions à poser aux
diplomates jean maurice ripert bonsoir
jean maurice ripert et merci beaucoup
d'être parmi nous ancien ambassadeur à
moscou et à pékin on va commencer par
par cette dernière question que vous
adressent marque au pommier dans son
sujet c'était hier emmanuel macron
parlement de strasbourg alors est-ce
qu'il a esquissé une troisième voie vous
allez nous le dire en tout cas il dit
bien sûr qu'il faut aider les ukrainiens
ça va de soi at il dit il a rappelé
vraiment le soutien inconditionnel de la
france et de l'union européenne qu'il
représente aux ukrainiens mais en même
temps il dit il ne faut ni cédés à
l'humiliation ni cédés à l'esprit de
vengeance est ce qu'on fout il est en
train d'essayer de penser à la presse
déjà est ce qu'il faut le faire c'est la
responsabilité de tous les chefs d'état
et en particulier du président d'un pays
qui exerce la présidence de l'union
européenne encore pour pour deux mois
préparer la paix il faut espérer quand
même que la paix reviendra j'espère que
on parlera aussi du fait que la paix est
loin qu'aujourd'hui alors m et pendant
que le président poutine essaye de faire
parler de parler ses troupes tue tous
les jours et notamment des civils des
femmes et des enfants je crois qu'il
faut le rappeler à tous les jours voilà
troisième fois je ne sais pas ce qu'a
dit le présent macro il a dit deux
choses il a dit un soutien total à
l'ukraine il a aussi dit à un moment et
je crois que c'est important c'est aux
ukrainiens de décider quand une séquence
diplomatique pourra se passer s'ouvrir
en attendant il continue à parler à
vladimir poutine il faut parler jeudi
les américains
depuis le début du conflit alors quelle
est la bonne foi président biden avec le
président poutine ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ya pas des contacts précis étonnée
qu'il n'y en ait pas du tout a lancé son
deux diplomates ont oublié ce qu'était
leur métier bon bien sûr les américains
sont plus loin d'abord
c'est l'europe qui est agressé en
premier lieu c'est aussi le monde
démocratique et ce sont les droits
humains partout à travers la planète la
démocratie partout à l'autre un la
plaine mais pour l'instant c'est le
continent européen qui est en guerre
parce que j'entends parfois qu'on dit la
guerre peu la guerre et aux portes de
l'europe non elle n'est pas en europe la
guerre et la cazine nous déclare nos
valeurs pour ce qu'on représente la
démocratie je pense qu'il ne faut pas
l'oublier des bâtons des ukrainiens
comme si c'était des martiens qui était
tombé en europe non ce sont autant le
chef de l'état l'a dit hier nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre sommes pas
en guerre contre la russie mais la
russie est en guerre contre l'ukraine a
agressé l'ukraine a enlevé l'ukraine et
cherche à détruire d'ukraine alors la
question que pose le président mac roncq
est importante pour tous les européens
c'est quelle est la place de l'europe
dans le soutien à une traîne dans la
sortie de crise dans le règlement du
conflit et dans la paix et la sécurité
future sur le continent c'est comme ça
qu'il faut interpréter le en même temps
qui doit fixer les buts de guerre parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont ceux là qui vont
aussi pouvoir déterminer d'une
éventuelle sortie est ce que ce sont les
ukrainiens qui pour l'instant 10 nous
voulons revenir aux frontières d'avant
l'invasion russe c'est compliqué le
président saint jean ce qui a aussi dit
est depuis longtemps c'est pour ça que
le discours venir poutine doit toujours
être apportées à l'arrêt lité défaite a
dit depuis longtemps j'ai compris que
l'ukraine n'entrerait pas dans le temps
donc il a déjà donné un gage au
président poutine il a aussi dit je suis
prêt à discuter du donbass je voudrais
rappeler aussi quelque chose que tout le
monde ait oublié jamais depuis 2002 puis
2014 les troupes ukrainiennes n'ont
cherché à reprendre le donbass qui a été
occupée par les russes par la force
jamais donc ils ont déjà donné des gages
de leur volonté de négocier raison des
fois défendu la progression de la russie
et ils ont participé au groupe de minsk
créant gagner à tort ce qui a marché qui
n'a pas marché très bien mais
aujourd'hui ce sont c'est à eux de
décider du moment où ils estimeront que
le coût de la guerre que leur impose que
leur inflige le dit mr poutine est telle
qu'il faut que ça s'arrête c'est à eux
de le décider le rôle de l'europe dans
un premier temps c'est d'aider l'ukraine
à se défendre pour que l'ukraine vivent
tout simplement à la dé suffisante
aujourd'hui on n'aide évidemment avec
les sanctions financières on allait on
livre des armes beaucoup plus qu'avant
d'ailleurs un peu moins que les états
unis les britanniques sans eau sans
aucun doute point que les américains
moins que les britanniques jeunes
anciens vous savez que le problème
compte que nous avons en france et je ne
suis pas dans le secret des dieux c'est
que nous communiquons peu sur nos z en
médecin militaire mais nous aidons aussi
à travers leur enseignement et toute une
série de choses qui sont faites
collectivement et puis nous travaillons
avec nos alliés il faut quand même pas
faire comme s'il y avait les américains
d'un côté les anglais de l'autre et les
européens donnent un troisième côté les
européens on travaille tous ensemble
heureusement vous avez parlé de cette
guerre en europe et non pas aux portes
de l'europe un mot sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne même si
évidemment ce n'est pas l'actualité du
jour mais le président français toujours
lors de ce discours à strasbourg hier a
douché les espoirs de l'ukraine de
rentrer un jour dans l'union pas avant
des années voire des décennies at il dit
est-ce que franchement c'était le bon
moment d'envoyer ce message aux
ukrainiens qui se bat pour nos valeurs
aussi il a aussi proposé une solution un
seul appareil moi je suis là ce que vous
avez signé une tribune dans l'express
intitulé
d'enseignants non j'ai dit que je
pensais que précisément face à quelqu'un
comme poutine qui veut nier l'existence
même de l'ukraine nous devons garantir
l'existence même de l'ukraine par un
geste symbolique
qui est d'octroyer le statut de candidat
à partir de là comme pour la serbie
comme pour l'albanie comme pour le
monténégro ce sont des années de
négociations moi j'ai représenté l'union
européenne en turquie ce sont des années
de négociations mais le geste doit être
fait pour dire vous êtes plus qu'un pays
européens de coeur vous êtes un pays
européen vous font peur
mais en même temps réduit elle est
peut-être un peu plus loin vous entend
allons jusqu'au bout il a aussi proposé
quelque chose extrêmement intéressant on
repart donnez moi j'ose interrompt parce
que justement on est bien voilà ce qu'il
a proposé emmanuel macron et hier à
cette communauté européenne politique
européenne vous réagissez juste après
pardonnez moi cette organisation
européenne nouvelles
permettraient aux nations européennes
démocratique adhérents à notre socle de
valeurs de trouver un nouvel espace de
coopération politique de sécurité de
coopération en matière énergétique de
transport
d'investissements d'infrastructures de
circulation des personnes et en
particulier de nos jeunesses voilà une
communauté politique européenne plus
large que l'union comme une sorte de sas
pour les pays qui veulent adhérer une
confédération au tour de l'europe on en
revient tout ce qui a été discuté dans
les années 80 à l'époque de françois
mitterrand du projet spinelli on a
beaucoup discuté de l'europe à plusieurs
vitesses qui a commencé en réalité un
schengen l'euro s'est déjà l'europe à
plusieurs vitesses puisque tout le monde
n'est pas dedans qu'est-ce que vous avez
compris
c'était il ya deux choses qui me
paraissaient trois choses qui me
paraissent importantes 1 c'est la porte
ouverte à des peuples qui attend des
peuples on parle pas que des temps on
parle de peuple qui attendent un je
pense à la géorgie je pensais avec
l'arménie je pense aux pays des balkans
à la moldavie bien sûr mais aussi et
cela concerne c'est important quelques
pays d'asie centrale qui ont pris leurs
distances avec moscou vous êtes
peut-être noté que le 9 mai hier le
kazakhstan l'ouzbékistan le kirghizistan
ont renoncé et n'ont pas organisé deux
défilés militaires le 9 mai c'est un
geste un symbole il commence à avoir
peur de la russie donc il est important
de leur dire si vous souhaitez
souhaitée la différence avec la russie
c'est que le président dit il faudrait
créer cet espace où vous pourrez entrer
si vous le souhaitez et pour bien
comprendre c'est un espace qui
permettrait qua non au fond d'en finir
avec les les élargissements mais en
ayant deux nouveaux partenaires on de
dire vous entrez d'abord dans ce grand
espace plus large avant peut-être un
jour d'être officiellement membre du
club les deux sont découplées et
parallèles en même temps il peut y avoir
il ya déjà des processus de négociation
de discussions sur l'adhésion dans
quelques-uns des pays qui sont concernés
pour l'adhésion mais ça va prendre des
années tout le monde le sait parce que
les critères de copenhague sur les
droits de l'homme parce que l'état de
l'économie et ses excès dans le même
temps pour ne pas perdre de temps
cette confédération c'est la possibilité
d'offrir toute une série de coopération
rasmussen minable qui permet à des
millions de jeunes de se promener en
europe de renforcer ce sentiment
européen collectif et puis de l'argent
bien sûr certainement des crédits de
coopération par là même quand on
s'intéresse à l'europe centrale et au
caucase c'est vrai aussi que on essaie
de proposer une alternative à quelques
danses chinoises et autres autour des
fameuses routes de la soie qui n'en sont
pas comme on le veau sri lanka
aujourd'hui nous revenons en justement à
la chine quel rôle joue exactement pékin
dans ce conflit on a du mal à comprendre
est ce que c'est une neutralité ambiguë
est ce que pékin était très surpris par
les déboires de l'armée russe et le
soutien des occidentaux
qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train de voir
et de comprendre de ce qui se passe avec
ce que je pense un peu de tout ça
d'abord je pense que les chinois
n'étaient certainement pas contents de
l'initiative prise par les russes
l'invasion d'un territoire étranger
c'est le contraire de ce que les chinois
essaye de promouvoir de manière bénévole
antho nations unies sur leur vision d'un
monde en paix et c est donc cette façon
qu'ont les russes de les obliger à venir
les soutenir ne leur plaît certainement
deuxièmement ils ont certaines ils ont
beaucoup disent avait en tout cas
beaucoup d'intérêt économique en ukraine
tout simplement aussi et ils ont un
intérêt commun dans
l'union européenne c'est le premier
marché le marché intérieur européen et
l'europe est le premier investisseur en
chine le premier partenaire commercial
qu'elle reste une envie de se lier au
sens géopolitique du terme le ministre
des affaires étrangères chinois a parlé
de moscou comme je crois d'un ami un roc
est ce que est ce que c'est vraiment le
cas 1 1 un ami solide comme un roc exact
j'ai assisté à pas mal de rencontres
entre vladimir poutine et si jean ping
qu'en gt2 d'abord à moscou puis à pékin
les communiqués sont toujours formidable
on signe des accords pour des dizaines
de milliards dont en général on ne voit
jamais la couleur alors j'espère pour
pour les pour les russes qu'ils environ
la couleur mais j'ai un vrai doute sur
le sujet non il ya un accord une zone
d'accord qui est importante c'est que
dans cette guerre lancée par les russes
contre le monde démocratique et les
droits de l'homme la chine est l'un
complètement derrière la russie parce
que la chine assume le fait de rejeter
le modèle démocratique à l'occidentale
entre guillemets pour le reste je pense
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus en concurrence
et je maintiens ce que je vous avais dit
à deux ans je pense que leur problème
c'est de rester le leader du monde avec
les etats-unis face aux états unis ça ne
se fait pas trois taïwanais il faut
absolument qu'on parle de ça parce que
évidemment on sur la chine est tout le
temps soupçonné de vouloir annexer
taiwan par la force est-ce que ce qui
s'est passé en ukraine et les sanctions
derrière pour la russie les a refroidis
de leurs plans ou pas c'est certainement
des objectifs en tout cas des états unis
et de beaucoup de pays du monde
asiatique et d'océanie vous pensez bien
que les japonais et les australiens
quand ils se joignent à la coalition et
aux sanctions c'est pas seulement parce
qu'ils aiment beaucoup l'ukraine c'est
aussi parce qu'ils ont seul en tête
c'est aussi pour cela que à mon avis les
chinois sont gênés par ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine c'est que ça a provoqué
un tel choc dans l'opinion publique
mondiale en tout cas dans ces pays
qu'ils se disent que ça rendrait plus
difficile une option militaire sur
taïwan mars
les posteurs on égrène les américains on
parlait de taiwan et donc ça pour les
chinois c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
machine qui est enfermé dans le piège de
0 qu'ovide la chine parking virus est
arrivé aujourd'hui avec ces méthodes
dictature sanitaire totalitaire
fragilisé aujourd'hui oui certainement
mais malheureusement pour le monde j'ai
envie de dire parce que nous avons tous
besoin aussi d'une chine prospère comme
nous aurions besoin d'une russie
prospère qui malheureusement se
condamnait le même pour l'instant en
tout cas pour que des années et
probablement une récession épouvantable
rien ne va changer au niveau du régime
il ya un congrès un combat je peux vous
l'annoncer à l'avant c'est un scoop rien
ne changera en revanche si je pense
qu'il ya un malaise dans l'opinion
publique celle où l on le voit et moi
les couplets rejet sur la façon dont
cette affairé gérez vous savez
souvenez-vous il ya quelques jours on a
découvert qu'il y avait un secrétaires
local du parti communiste qui posait des
barres de fer sur les portes des
immeubles pour empêcher les gens de
sortir et aujourd'hui on leur a été
interdit les livraisons de nourriture à
domicile juste pas comment on va nourrir
les gens dans des tours qui font 50
étages à shanghai c'est une catastrophe
absolue donc question est quand même le
particulier est sensible à l'état de
l'opinion publique il ya une opinion
publique en chine même si elle est
manipulée beaucoup parler de nouvelle
guerre froide ont essayé d'esquisser
nouvel ordre mondial dans lequel on est
en train d'entrer c'est juste c'est pas
juste le pense qu'on est plus du tout
dans la guerre froide on est dans la
guerre chaude la guerre froide c'était
justement la prévention de
l'intervention militaire sauf exception
des super grand c'était l'affrontement
l' équilibre de la terreur laurie dire
qu'on va quoi mais va ouvrir un une page
de guerre dans notre espoir nouvelle
avec le nouveau jeu de la dissuasion
nucléaire en gros vous avez l'armé
nucléaire ont tourné attaquer votre
voisin ceci n'est pas dans l'otan
personne ne vous dira rien cette partie
là de la guerre froide l' équilibre de
la terreur et les clips nucléaire
espérons le en tout cas restera et
demeurera mais on n'est plus dans
le respect des zones d'influencé si je
puis dire et c'est pour ça que la russie
se sent libre d'essayer de se
reconstituer une comme au bon vieux
temps de l'urss stalinienne pour
terminer cet entretien qu est ce que
vous dites à la jeune génération qui
rend dans un monde hyper crise
réchauffement climatique pandémie guerre
savent elles durent faut se préparer on
était dans un cocon en europe pour se
réveiller durée il faut se mobiliser il
faut se mobiliser il faut pas juste il
faut évidemment être consciente du
danger mais il ne faut pas accepter
il ne faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain si vous me passez cette
expression populaire la mise en cause de
la démocratie par des dictatures ça ne
veut pas dire que la démocratie ça ne
marche pas comme disait churchill la
démocratie c'est le pire des modèles à
l'exception de tous les autres bon bah
merci beaucoup merci jean maurice ripert
vous rester avec moi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nono a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir j'ai nommé jean rémi
baudot pour la politique qui va nous
parler du mouton à cinq pattes le
premier ministre parfait existe-t-il
pour emmanuel macron et puis fanny
guinochet pour l'économie alerte rouge
écarlate sur notre déficit commercial
nous affranchit très bon saint flour tv
et radio ce soir bienvenue les voici
bonsoir à vous deux on va commencer avec
la politique jean rémy alors on est
toujours en attente du casting du
nouveau gouvernement même si le portrait
robot de la ou du premier ministre safin
un peu et le suspense est intense
relancer d'ailleurs hier par emmanuel
macron lui-même depuis berlin le
président a dit qu'il connaissait le nom
de son futur premier ministre quoi
évidemment relancé les spéculations
alors l'idée n'est pas ce soir de
relater la longue liste des noms qui
circulent pour matignon mais pour
ajouter un peu un peu de fun dans cette
attente je vous propose de jouer bien
mais pas si vous vous souvenez du jeu
qui s mais vierge qui a fait le bonheur
des enfants dans les années 80 voilà on
vous rappelle le principe est assez
facile on tente de trouver un personnage
en posant des questions et à la fin
normalement il n'en reste plus qu'un
alors on sait que le prochain chef du
gouvernement doit pouvoir porter un
projet écolo voilà emmanuel macron l'a
dit il s'agirait de quelqu'un qui je
cite est attaché à la question sociale à
la question environnementale
et à la question productive ça fait déjà
quelques personnes en moins le nom en
fête qui sera annoncé par l'elysée
donnera la tonalité sur l'écologie
véritable mue ou bluff de communication
le temps évidemment sera donnée mais
reprenant la prochaine personne à matino
devrait être quand même technique
capable de réformer elle devrait n'avoir
aucun dossier judiciaire bon ça on
acronis et on enlève quelques-uns ce
sera aussi une personne qui a du
charisme pour gérer la campagne des
législatives mais pas d'ambitions
présidentielles on a vu ce que ça a
donné avec edouard philippe une personne
malgré tout un peu politique mais pas
trop pour que richard ferrand puisse
continuer à organiser des dîners de la
majorité puis globalement quelqu'un qui
accepte de prendre des coups par loyauté
alors emmanuel macron a aussi laissé
entendre que ce serait une personnalité
de gauche la wii une personnalité de
gauche et puis une femme alors si j'en
crois mes calculs c'est maria avec le
chapeau vert et les boucles d'oreilles
bon blague à part ma petite
démonstration elle est là pour vous dire
qu'ils empruntent de banc de touche en
macro ni il n'est pas très fourni il ya
un vrai sujet reconnaissez un ministre
cette semaine à qui j'en ai parlé quand
un fidèle des fidèles des manuels macron
me disait on dit toujours qu emmanuel
macron hésiter met du temps à choisir le
problème c'est que personne ne veut
venir c'est comme ça depuis 2010 cette
fin de citation alors au delà de la
question du gouvernement macron ça doit
peut-être nous interpeller sur
l'attractivité du poste de premier
ministre personne n'y fait fortune c'est
un job vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre totalement critiquer ça
peut se terminer à tout instant il faut
avoir l'état chevillée au corps alors là
ce soir j'ai sous le choisit qui est ce
on verra si la semaine prochaine de
revenir avec le 1000 bornes par exemple
quoi qu'il en soit pour ceux qui en
doutaient former un gouvernement et un
casse tête qui n'a rien d'un jeu
d'enfant merci infiniment
jean régnier jean maurice ripert vous
avez bien connu beaucoup de premiers
ministrables chaque casque qu'est ce qui
coince là c'est roger cedetim
entablement l'on vous vous comprenez ce
qui se passe c'est le mouton à cinq
pattes je suis pas là je peux un
politique donc je peux juste vous donner
un scoop ce ne sera pas moins oui
mais on n'a jamais vu ça sur la vème
république
on a un gouvernement qui ne peut plus
travailler
mais on apprend dans ce parlement on est
aussi sur un continent en guerre à la
sortie d'une crise terrible j'imagine
que vous allez en parler crise
énergétique une frise climatique une
pandémie
j'ai vraiment fantôme actuellement est
ce que la situation n'est pas figée là
et qu'on se retrouve dans une période où
finalement on n'a plus vraiment de
gouvernement on a un président qui
attend et qui va mettre du temps à
relancer la machine
dans les secteurs qui me qui me concerne
c'est vrai que par exemple changer de
mise des affaires étrangères changer de
ministre des armées en pleine guerre en
europe c'est un vrai sujet quand même
c'est pas sûr que j'avais rien qu'on
peut constamment avant les mois qui
viennent mais c'est vrai qu'on se pose
la question au fond matignon ne séduit
plus
c'est parce que en gros maquereau a tué
le job il décide de tout
on a l'impression des tickets qui les
suit un peu vieux mais on a aussi dit
qu'il y avait une malédiction de
matignon pour ceux qui voulaient devenir
président oui d'abord c'est en fait
j'aime en témoigner
mais ça ne se refusait pas et encore des
années on vous proposait matignon
je le reconnais plus aujourd'hui à la
question qui se pose c'est dans les noms
qui ont circulé depuis quelques temps
qui est ce qu'on a vraiment proposé
matignon à ces personnalités prenons par
exemple valérie rabault j'en discutais
avec un membre du gouvernement qui
doutaient que certainement on a dû lui
parler mais il doutait qu'on lui ait
proposé réellement matignon donc il ya
aussi on le sait un jeu de bluff qui est
en train de se mettre en place et puis
je pense malgré tout qu'il ya des gens
qui refusent parfois pour des raisons
familiales la patronne de nexity
numéro de nexity
elle a refusé certains souffrent que des
raisons familiales derrière on voit que
sa famille a dit t'es gentil il faudrait
une femme en tout cas vous pensez jean
maurice ripert par mois je ça serait
sûrement la voiture on a eu nos fennecs
le faire neuf athlètes femmes à matignon
on peut pas dire que le score de cette
république se trouve rien non pas que ce
soit le problème essentiel on voit bien
que vous êtes resté diplomate dans l'âme
en tout cas le respect de la parité au
gouvernement ça c'est fondamental oui ça
je crois quand même une question de
modernité politique qu'est ce qu'il ya
des attentes sociales par rapport à ça
alors je suis sûr que ça vous
intéresserait également parlé du déficit
commercial 100 milliards d'euros fanny
c'est un seuil les symboliques il a été
franchi et c'est un coup très dur pour
notre économie effectivement et c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle pour le second
mandat de d'emmanuel macron de démarrer
sur ce ce chiffre astronomique alors le
déficit commercial on leur rappelle
c'est évidemment la différence entre ce
que nous vendons est ce que nous
achetons à l'étranger et c'est un vrai
plongeon rien que sur le premier
trimestre on est à plus de 30 milliards
d'euros alors à quoi séduire et bien à
la guerre en ukraine notamment qui fait
flamber les cours des carburants de
l'énergie du pétrole du gaz qui se soit
envolé un + 19 % en trois mois mais
aussi tous les produits qui sont qui en
découlent qui sont facturés est fabriqué
en fonction de ces carburants dans la
chimie la métallurgie et qui eux aussi
ont vu leur tarif augmenter alors ça
c'est pour les raisons conjoncturelles
il ya des raisons plus profondes un plus
ancrée et oui parce qu'elle a ce déficit
ça montre qu'on est incapable de
produire les biens dont on a besoin et
qu'on achète beaucoup à l'étranger alors
ça veut dire aussi que le quoi qu'il en
coûte ces milliards d'euros qui ont
profité aux ménages français bien les
ménages français les ondes dépensés pour
acheter de l'électronique qui venaient
d'asie du textile qui venait du
bangladesh des voitures qui n'étaient
plus produite sur notre sol ça révèle un
malaise très très profond de notre
économie ça montre que nos produits ne
sont pas assez compétitifs pas assez
innovant prenez par exemple la pharmacie
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'était un
fleuron français bien on a vu sanofi le
patron de sanofi plus ou moins fait ses
excuses il ya quelques semaines on n'a
pas été capable de faire un max 1 contre
le coc vides ont rassuré nous il ya
quand même des domaines dans lequel on
est leader il en vend quelques produits
locaux lors l'aéronautique le luxe mais
hélas ce sont des des secteurs qui ont
pâti de la crise du coc vide
l'aéronautique sans mauvais jeu de mot
airbus a pris un coup dans les ailes du
côté du luxe la chine qui est
reconfirmer bien c'est autant de
produits de sacs vuitton qu'on ne peut
pas leur vendre il ya aussi les
milliardaires russes qui aimait bien
acheter nos produits de beauté est bien
là forcément avec l'embargo ça supprime
aussi des marchés alors heureusement il
nous reste le vin français qui s'exporte
très bien qui marche très bien quand je
dis vin c'est toute la fille va pas y
compris - la champagne cognac etc mais
ça ne suffit pas alors pour s'en sortir
il faudrait une vraie politique
industrielle des usines qui reviennent
en france des chercheurs qui restent en
france parce que ils innovent ils
fondent et des brevets mais ça prendrait
du temps et puis à un moment où on se
dit que emmanuel macron risque d'aider
les français à combattre l'inflation en
déversant encore un peu d'argent ou des
milliards d'euros bien on peut aussi se
dire que malheureusement c'est de
l'argent qui va permettre de faire
tourner les usines à l'étranger et ce
qui en plus du déficit commercial va
creuser notre déficit budgétaire ce qui
est mauvais les messieurs jean maurice
ripert la diplomatie commerciale ça fait
partie du travail d'un ambassadeur en
suisse que les coûts
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'on a raté
pour en arriver là 100 milliards de
déficit commercial on nous parle
d'autonomie
stratégique de souveraineté industrielle
même la ratatouille quand vous la
fabrique et vous apporter plus de
légumes comme on en trouvait sur notre
sable ça a été très bien expliqué dans
les facteurs conjoncturels si j'ai bien
compris quand même le creusement
actuelle et aussi beaucoup liée au
renchérissement des importations
c'est-à-dire que
si tant il est creusé
il avait tendance à aller plutôt mieux
mais c'est vrai que tous les problèmes
qui ont été évoqués me paraît juste et
ceux auxquels on est confrontés quand on
est dans des ambassades et qu'on essaie
de promouvoir
l'industrie et de travail principalement
ce dans quoi je ne crois pas je ne le
crois pas et d'ailleurs les efforts de
productivité ont été faits le
différentiel avec l'allemagne et 2 n'est
plus aussi important qu'il était
autrefois on a perdu une base
industrielle ça me paraît absolument
évident enfin l'innovation vous avez
cité
les vaccins mais le doliprane enfin le
paracétamol c'est incroyable quand soit
pas capable d'avoir un seul à revenir
enfin
il ya quelques gimmicks et c'est
l'innovation n'a jamais su vraiment
investir dans la vie nos charges
économie du futur reprenez le nucléaire
on a aussi des filières qu'ils perdent
ou qu'ils perdent en compétences on a
vendu des ep air mais on voit bien la
difficulté qu 'est et bruno le maire qui
était qu'est donc ministre de l'économie
disait bien avant le conflit en ukraine
que c'était le point noir le point de
fragilité de l'économie française et que
l'économie française d'hier est
nettement mieux certes il ya le taux de
chômage à tout un tas d'indicateurs mais
effectivement les déficits comme après
confiance de du problème en haut lieu
jean rémy oui il arrête pas de dire que
depuis cinq ans ils ont fait beaucoup de
choses sur l'attractivité sur la le
retour des capitaux les ouvertures du
film est en réalité s'il ya des juges
trois défaites mais ça ne suffit pas sûr
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci jean
maurice ripert pour votre éclairage très
belle soirée sur lcp émission spéciale
depuis strasbourg du parlement européen
enregistré par votre serviteur
hier à la faveur de ce discours d'
emmanuel macron mais surtout du dernier
volet de notre série documentaire
consacrée à la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe très belle foire et allemand
[Musique]